and someone kindly lent me their laser
pointer so I could actually should
actually see the dot so I will talk
about a number of papers that website
you can't hear okay so a gentleman back
there has to turn me on the good that
sounds better no I me this little closer
okay let's try that okay is that more
audible okay it's not exactly a Roman
apathetic here so i will talk about some
work done with paul-françois over the
years who is now at mcgill in the
physics and biology so what I am
concerned with is development and
particularly developmental phenotypes
and that of course is by definition a
matter of time and dynamics this happens
of course a through progressive
refinement of patterns and I should note
rather forcefully for the non biologist
among you that although we have great
volumes of data many genomes many chip
seek RNA seek seek seek whatever these
things collectively tell us virtually
nothing about developmental dynamics ie
if you were to hand to some person these
vast data collections done for a sea
urchin and a frog he could not tell you
we cannot predict from those vast
collections whether at later times what
would immersion the embryo is in fact
sea urchin or frog there is no dynamics
no morphology in those vast data sets
that one can discern obviously if one's
thinking about dynamics one has to think
about dynamical systems geometry and
bifurcations of flows as you know from
applied mathematics so my proposition
will be which I will answer
affirmatively in several very specific
cases that the mere fact that a that I
can evolve through positive selection a
pattern generating system of equations
will be I assert a grounds for saying
that is what we might see in the real
world so I'm going to use this very
simple notion night of 19th century
Darwinism by positive selection
implications of course are that assuming
that you know what we see is what's
quick to evolve so if you like survival
the fleet 'used and of course the fact
that I claim there is some mechanism
here means that there is some degree of
convergence in these dynamical
patterning mechanisms at the level of
phenotype of course the genetic
implementation can be much more
contingent so in comparison with things
you have heard for the past couple of
days this talk is rather near
engineering in other words a very
specific solution to a very specific
problem the virtue of which I maintain
is that it's very obvious if you're
wrong ie if your bridge falls down is
clear you had troubles so that perhaps
is good an area where hard theoretical
your hard experimental and theoretical
results and their confrontation are
fairly rare so to be more explicit the
setup involves that I have to define
what type of pattern I want to make so i
will look at embryos on the scale of a
phyla and i will say certain patterns
are prevalent in this class of embryos i
will then make up a fitness that favors
that class of patterns this has nothing
to do with reproductive fitness and i
will then evolve a dynamical system
which will make that pattern in response
the boundary conditions presented by the
embryo the representation for what i
will show you is dynamical systems built
from what you might call pseudo
biochemical biomimetic like parts one
imposes a simple dynamics ie that the
long time limit of my economical models
are either fixed points or cycles one
obviously evolves both the network and
the parameters and one just proceeds
through neutral or fitness increasing
changes and in this for this particular
problem that i will show you although i
will lewd to others the setup is that
you will you will mutate evolve the
network you will then use it to time
evolved from the initial conditions to
the end and at the final time you
evaluate the fitness of the resulting
pattern and then you will accept or
reject obviously there was an issue here
of how much my choice of fitness matters
do my mutation rates on the network and
parameters matter these latter issues
are somewhat controlled by the
assumption that we're just going to look
at positive selection so if the endpoint
is a unique certainly cisely how I get
there doesn't much matter I will get
there the Canadian problems with giving
the network the morphology infinite time
to form no no it's all aboard one every
is water one simple problems and that's
for the same reason issues of the
previous couple of days simply do not
arise everything is small and there's no
issue of learning concept classes what
example work just fine the evaluating
Fitness is very steps along the way in
this particular case it is of the time
endpoint obviously each network has its
own fitness but the fitness is evaluated
as a result as in development you run
from embryo to adult and then your
fitness is assessed on the adult so
we're looking at the long time limit of
the network which of course is
continually challenged by evolution an
example of this set up is what Nick
Martin Martin called quantity of
genetics ie these people took on the
challenge of involving an eye quantity
of genetics as defined yesterday means
that we have our organs have a bunch of
traits these traits are continuous there
perhaps there's perhaps one percent
standing variation of population it's
partially inheritable and anything can
vary and off you go so these people show
that if you define fitness as visual
acuity as calculated by physical optics
then if you start from a photosensitive
patch and let it go and allow all
properties of the material to vary
refractive index shape etc you will
evolve through a sequence of fitness
increasing changes at a camera I with a
very nice lens and i recommend the
for to your attention and it's fast what
yes there was no fits it assumes that
you're essentially it is effectively as
I consuming your Gaussian of course no
llores and deviations away from them no
no no no it's step by step and whatever
it talks about the generations variation
yeah of course it's it's what he called
quantitative genetics precisely right
and that's probably a good idea for many
things it does not like precisely okay
so here is my model organism shown here
it is reasonable to abstract and biology
that embryonic patterns are Cartesian
there is a anterior posterior g network
and a dorsal ventral g network and you
take the direct product as i've said
before you you develop this by pad and
refinement it is also reasonable to
assume the best evidence was developed
for fly in the 80s or 70s and 80s that
there are things called selector genes
which define the cell types and body
parts underneath them so basically the
task of morphology is to correctly
position the selected genes and what
happens downstream is another package of
the module so this organism would be
then described by some pattern of
selected genes which are arrayed from
head to tail in the appropriate color
code matching the pieces of the
hypothetical tetrapod okay a little bit
more on the methods which I will not
otherwise go on so we will evolve
networks by mutation selection obviously
the network topology shall change the
parameter cell change and in addition we
allow the subset of variables called
outputs those on which the fitness is
assessed to vary ie in a court of the
idea of co-option it's not a priori
Garrett is you're not a priori told
which genes are to be the things on
which will define the pattern so that
also revolves we will take we're looking
at just enter your posterior patterning
we will take a line of blobs I call
themselves but they're sort of
territories
the networks that i will show you cat
all function without direct cell-cell
communication though other problems we
obviously add those effects and the
cleaning height term a morphogen will be
a generic term for some protein that
sets the initial symmetry breaking which
is then refined to the pattern air can I
talk to your first one tell me if I
write this in a loose sense the first
one is saying is some function but which
variables that function is all yeah you
know true they provides many possible
right right so um shark was one input
one output the output shall be the
fitness then of course you allow
yourself the output can flip around you
make you make you may create more
selective jeans what you call so you can
remove any notion co-option is that
sometimes jeans can change function so
if something's around to allow a boost
to use it it's not insane so interaction
of the interactions have a rather
transcriptionally an inspired functional
form like this which you probably have
seen before which was obviously
mentioning the first talk on Monday
morning so relatively standard set of
interactions okay so now how do i cook
up a fitness for embryonic patterning
what I wish to do is I have to take any
set of selected genes as a function of
position and assign a number to them I
wish the fitness to encourage diversity
IE I want many selected genes in the
embryo I want to complicated embryo I
want however a well-defined embryo ie
for a given position X I want minimal
diversity right I want to always put my
heart here and not here and in addition
you want a smooth function which
obviously rewards a little bit of
pattern ie you don't want to search in a
golf course landscape ok so how do we
cook this up ok so we say that we will
define something that I will treat as a
probability in quotation marks which
will just be the normalized
concentration of selector gene I at
position X so think of this as P of I
given X I will assume that all cells are
equally interesting or
important for the organism and I will
compose of these two things 882 variable
life probability which involves the
selector identity I and the position X
the smite criterion are for maximum
diversity I will express in terms of
entropy naturally which is to say that
if i look at p of I little is just a
number of the selected genes I and play
I want a lot of them IE i want p log
minus p log p to be large so i want big
diversity of selectors however I want
minimum diversity given X which I could
express similarly as minimum entropy of
the conditional probability I give an X
so s2 should be small s one should be
large by my criteria I have two terms
how do i combine them it is very natural
to assert that if I do a gene
duplication IE i take gene a in its
position and i duplicated to a prime
both expressed in identical position i
haven't made a better or worse embryo I
simply have put two marks on the same
position therefore my fitness should be
invariant to gene duplication and if you
then carry through the calculation you
see that only one combination of these
two parameters will be invariant to gene
duplication and that is naturally enough
to mutual information between I and X is
this context the gene duplication
reversibility a gene duplication will be
that I simply have my variables as a
function of concentration one through
ten and i will make verbal 11 which will
be a copy of 10 in identical position i
will all the formulas again and I will
observe that this combination is
invariance I'm only one of the right
which is not ridiculous okay and of
course it has the very nice intuitive
meaning that what I want to optimize is
the mutual information between position
and gene identity so that's what you
mean in quantity by complex organism
right everything your selector j's are
tied to position you know position to
selecting or selecting your position and
the quality of that matching is mutual
information very natural um
and okay so an admission here my
ancestors spent many years minimizing
something called F and i will also
minimize f although i'll call fitness so
i will slip so the best fitness we could
have is minus log N and it given n
selectors yes this is I meant to be the
theme ism I is meant to be the identity
of a particular select urg'd and it will
then give rise to type I body parts n is
the number of selected genes or the car
and is a number of selected genes right
so far n jeans I can't do better than
that by definition of mutual information
X be much larger but typically x is
bigger than n the number of slept is
right it should be one can write L
doesn't enter elders L accepts it as a
line of cells and typically have more
cells than then n as you will say
typically but don't have to okay so to
fix the definitions this configuration
would be a fitness of minus 1.5 logged
1.5 if I make the two territories equal
that is optimal for to selector jeans ie
I in this configuration I know as much
as possible about position given the
chemistry so i divide it obviously if i
add another selector so i have 1 2 3
selectors which are the solid colors
this has a configuration of lon 2.3 and
if i make the territories equal i
optimize the mutual information and i
get minus log 3 so this this is this is
the fitness right that clear very
straightforward you can give you have
three cylinders and and I position them
so I so is derived from the chemistry
maximum information about where I am in
position I have to make them equal in on
overlapping and this is in fact downhill
ok but so the loss is invariant to
shifting around where the cross the
border line no I have to make each
territory equal because it's mutual
information between position and
identity Oh mutual information therefore
it you want equal sized territories
mutual information but what why can't I
tell like oh because you can only like
I'm only ought to see relative
concentration of relative right yeah so
why make that assumption yop because you
could the downstream plan could always
adjust levels like there's there's level
in variance in the in the chemistry so I
thought that if you actually like looked
at a Drosophila embryo it could be
sensitive to the absolute concentration
yes it is but its relative when things
overlap they're less informed about
where you are this is slight this is
someone idealize I'm well over bulletin
biochemistry this is slightly idealized
but not grossly rollator is not about
and yep salons don't hurt anything these
these are very robust simple-minded
arguments which is their virtue there's
content here you'll be surprised okay
now so now we're now we want the machine
okay so i will show you one example and
then draw some conclusions so the deal
is that i'm going to start with a
morphogen which is going to define head
to tail the water will be on for
wellness the offer this is the fitness
as a function of generation for my
machine this is one particular final
network where the morphogen is shown as
the inverted triangle the jeans and the
network are these ovals and the selected
genes for which i compute the fitness
are the other triangles so they have a
bunch of selectors they just really
started with sent seven gene no no no I
start I start with one input and one
output so I know so the things are
defined one input and one output which
is which are not connected in fact I
start with a more fitted to define the
geometry and symmetry breaking and I
take one gene so the first operation
will be connect morphogen to gene okay
so i will show you a movie now of the
dynamics defined by this network it just
goes so i start with nothing i start
with the vacuum
wishin marks and if we want patient
which we're probably not this morphogen
so there's more fitting to show down
here a little bit collapsed it will
disappear in a moment if we care to wait
which we probably don't but this pattern
will change slightly not much and this
is a fitness of minus log 7 and if we're
a patient the warmest appears things
change a bit and that's my final state
manifestly the final state is multi
stable because this sits here in the
absence of morphogen so we have done
this many times of course and let us
then we capitulate properties of these
networks so they they are set up by
definition to be cell autonomous no
communication between the cells the
morphogen defines itself position since
the morphogen disappears in the pattern
remains there is multi stability and the
point the the accomplishment of the gene
network is that by virtue of this rather
gradual morphogen it has chosen a
particular arrangement in the multi
stable landscape and taught it in a
unique way with position right every
cell is identical at the beginning they
simply see different morphogen levels
which are not you know not over a huge
range and in the end of the day you have
a multi stable system where each cell
has dropped into the appropriate
territory then the territories your
angels in word no no it's not you know
biology they're not that has you know it
got worked up to reproduce use just the
long seven required the movies no no no
i said i said help me to hit the optimal
bound I mean there's there's 10 there
okay something's here beautiful yes to
the resident questions
so you start from a string of cells with
no pattern of expression correct correct
correct correct right right in this
clears everything is 0 and initial about
and for the evolution no network 0 yes
the mutual information you defined is
invariant to permutations of yes mutual
no no it's mutual information between
position and and I the end color color
therefore I always want to put eight in
the same position so if my network were
very unstable and through things around
then the relationship between the
average density of whatever mustard and
position would be very spread up not be
bad news but I'm definitely favoring
having a lock-in you know it's knows the
distribution of I given X should be
tight no information yes but the eggs
could be commuted so X is X right x is 1
through 20 but wait I me know if I knew
that I was at either end of the organism
yeah wouldn't I have just as much mutual
information if I news in the same
question each position house is if each
cell was weighted equally and it's the
mutual information between X and gene
identity so there's no there's no reason
why x and x + 1 having the same not
matter is it and I know there's no North
there's no cell communication however
because of the smoothness of parameters
there tends to be correlation between
adjacent subsequently the genes are
similar because the genes are served are
seeing several levels of more potential
yes yes precise like the workers
continue to try which is completely
reasonable for up to continuous and all
these are diffusing to all there is this
cell autonomous no sorry oh yeah they
don't talk to each other but the fact
that they are seeing a smooth morphogen
and we have smooth equations means that
this continent asleep except that there
then these dumps between various faiths
we I would maintain that you're thinking
about Hawks pirating the hox genes don't
defuse among themselves the stuff
upstream does this the mortgage and
stuff does at the hot at the selector
gene level that they typically do not
you know just elicit so do not diffuse
the simplest you want to see it is also
the simplest but it's not crazy right
the upstream stuff i will show you
exactly the upstream stuff manifestly
refuses that this level does not yes of
the model soon so see you have
it's a new colors right if I declare it
if evolution wishes to select it as a
selector Jade which is also a random
event it will then put it in my selector
gene list compute the fitness function
give it a new color no no at this cell
autonomous cellet ogress which this is
not a surprise right this is the Bulge
of the little are you i wish it it's
inherited okay i know he's here good
where did he go through it evolved i
started with nothing a greater from what
you have solution mutations and so yeah
yes of arbitrary and garbage i put it i
make i make i add thinks the number move
things that we're a change parameters do
this end of that dog tree numbers and as
you downhill and you allow these two are
activated regret yes the functions i
showed you right at the app called hours
or what it involves but the feature of
all these networks is more or less is
that the mortgage in level sets the
anterior boundary of the particular
domains and repression from the
posterior sets the posterior boundary
not a surprise you see this in natural
systems it's what you might have guessed
if you are clever then we were so I put
the perimeters you're changing or
parameters this dynamical system of
which this is a fixed point yes of which
this solution is a fixed point solution
like so we change the network we change
all parameters and network we evolved
from nothing and we optimize the fitness
which is mutual formation nothing
there's nothing up my sleeves do your
some senses whether it be easy for this
to get 202 well no cuz they are many
other that's impossible bunch of other
zoology they all have the same
phenotypic properties as discussed to
you okay this gets more interesting okay
now look at while G you know probably
know that in violet Aryans
anteroposterior patterning is carried by
means remarkable concerned Hawks James
they define the AP coordinates they're
so like zip code and the biochemistry of
the regulation is immensely complex the
phenomenology is simple another picture
of hawks of hox genes into the mouse
vertebrae and when you get
mutation hox genes you will move around
these various territories and they are
easy to track by means of the different
shaped vertebrae from the humble mouse
okay so phenomenology firstly remarkably
and due to their remarkable regulation
the the order on the genome follows
their expression anterior to posterior
very unusual in vertebrates if I look at
the order in which they are expressed
that will match the temporal or from
enter to posterior the temple
automatically positional order the
posterior privilege rule is that the
most posterior Hawks imposes its face on
the anterior geez ie in this very famous
case from at Lewis there is a small
balancer Oregon here which when you make
a Hawks mutation converts the whole tier
2 a wing but with this sort of logical
diagram that of course shows that
development is modular IE I made a
perfect wing where there was a whole
tier so the depth so what is downstream
of these selected genes is very modular
at the selected gene level itself it is
not and that is of course why among
other reasons that these these networks
that give rise the body plan are common
across filing they're very hard to
change so these are the phenomenology a
development is quite remarkable and this
is the Frog which goes from egg to
tadpole swimming in two days flat if it
doesn't become food for the fishes to
show you more detail what actually
happens to a frog embryo as it gassed
relates goes from the sphere sphere to
the cylinder you see that here so what
has happened is in almost 17 hours is
that you basically start with a sphere
there's a northern hemisphere so to
speak which is future Ecuador but
southern hemisphere which is endoderm
and equatorial region which is mesoderm
of the process of gastrulation will take
the equator converge it towards the
Greenwich Meridian slide it down pushing
the end
in along gating building the
anterior-posterior axis and you see the
embryo at a stage where you have an open
girl plate ahead here the future anus
down there a little plate will then
close the point of showing you this
remarkable video is that I need to
motivate my choice of boundary condition
for when I look at vertebrate hawks
patterning so what happens is so this is
the experiment to showed these people
have looked at Hawks expression in that
in a frog embryo they see the sequence
of they see a temple progression of hox
genes expressed on the equatorial band
which is converging and coming downward
at that temple progression is then
locked in to an anterior-posterior
pattern as those territories move to the
Greenwich Meridian dive under and then
elongate along the neighborhood so the
point of this which maybe with a little
bit fast is to motivate the boundary
condition that I'm going to use on
vertebrates which is to say I'm going to
idealize the three-dimensional
morphology of gastrulation by simply
saying i have my line of cells which
will be the future anterior-posterior
axis and i run a morphogen across them
and then demand at the end maximum
mutual information so I've changed the
boundary condition from the static
morphogen to this wave that moves across
the line of cells and because that is in
keeping with what happens in vertebrates
so I do that and the computer chums away
and I now produce another network so my
morphogen is moving across the network
here chubs away various hox genes are
produced and this is the terminal
Network and I see five territories in
response the slaadi morphogen
so this can be done quite robustly if I
look at those patterns I will discover
technical entirety ID if i look at the
spatial order of gene expression we're
trying to showed you and I then compare
it with the temple progression in a
fixed cell in the posterior the cell the
posterior of that cell expresses a
sequence of oxygen which mirror follow
the anteroposterior progression so we
have obtained one of these hawks
phenomenology of properties which is to
say the temple order matches the spatial
order the anterior home documentation
can also be similarly produced for sort
of trivial reasons that is to say if I
mutate gene eight the territory of five
moves back and that is because again
there is neutral repression between the
territories I mutate the green one and
the purple one moves back so that again
is the is the property displayed in
these remarkable flies from at Lewis so
to recapitulate again i showed you
firstly a static morphogen where the
anterior boundaries were position from
the morphogen what is the analogous
remark for the sliding gradient which
you just saw well what evolution does is
having solved one problem if uses it
again so what evolution does is when you
give it a boundary condition which this
sliding this the sliding wave of
morphogenic what it does is create a
timer gene so that time regime simply
says I will go up in proportion amount
of time I spend with in that step that
is something which is proportional to
the anterior-posterior distance it then
uses that time regine war or less as it
did the static morphogen to then
position the selector genes this is of
course a good way for the controlled
growth because obviously in something
like a frog the growth time will vary by
a factor of two is temperature
as it doesn't fly and one could even
speculate about the identity of that
timer the gene 3 emerges the only thing
you provided is my Trojan right right
right you put in the bad person that
emerges in some number of cases nothing
like the values meaning this time
depends yes yes and you put your finger
of the subnet look at this gingery gene
3 is one gene so is this this is rather
well it's not a selector gene it's an
internal genes the network this also has
the interesting feature which I will
show you so so so so we have arrived at
the Hawks phenomenology by and during
this evolution calculation in response
to this boundary gated which obviously
have derived by looking at the embryo
the other very interesting thing that
this little calculation shows you is how
the transition from so-called long to
short germ band insects may occur so the
relevant biology is shown here so what a
insect person calls short is like the
vertebrate mode ie you first pattern the
head and then you grow the trunk and
abdomen and as you grow you pattern so
it's patterning with growth that's short
term long term is drosophila like the
static morphogen you have the entire
body laid out and then parallel in time
you pattern anterior and posterior now
if you look at the phylogeny so fly is
down here and various other creatures up
here etc you will see that there is a
mixture of long and short germ
patterning if you're interested a is a
first-rate lab here of a new palm pre
tell who's ten minutes from here who has
consumed a lot to this area anyway you
see an intermingling of long and short
term short term so called sequential is
the ancestral state long is derived now
the question is how do you change the
patterning systems inc which seems very
complex what i just showed you gives you
a very natural way to move
from short to long term name will you
take the timer gene which is there for
the short gerb sequential patterning and
you simply freeze it and call it the
morphogen that has the virtue of
changing only one gene and allowing you
to keep invariant all the downstream
stuff so there's great complexity
between the zoology of that of those
networks was downstream that can be left
invariant you simply have to change the
timer and make it static so a change at
a high level makes very easy to go from
short to long without interrupting all
the complex stuff downstream yes so this
is what you said now the last sentence
is to explain this complexity that these
were called well convex we say open on
the treaty to do the convergence of
these characters characters yes it is
expose the fact that you have you have
derived more from short many times yes
it's a fact ok questions only because of
one gene this is what we suggest right
there's no data we suggest that it has
happened many times fact we suggest a
expression with that is that you can in
or within these calculations which are
derived from this crazy simulation it
predicts that there is something called
a selector gene which becomes opposed to
real morphogen when you go from long to
go from short to long prediction or in
other words the non parsimonious it is
really young but Simone geez Finn on ya
know cuz i get eat as easy changes it's
an easy change no you don't have to
don't have to recreate all the
downstream stuff which is complex that
is fixed as we know it's tequila genes
effects you know that downstream stop is
fixed the options that has changed how
does this happen without destroying the
insect well we suggest one and it can be
continuous you baking degrees of dynamic
right there's a family of dynamical
systems of kinds of interactions yeah
yeah what you have here yes would you
didn't chose correct Bert went by so
fast yeah I didn't show you i mean it's
it's in the computer has found it
between of us
what kind of mutation you have some
underlying large family of possible
Daniel system yes yes yes which but that
you don't have to pick up early you pick
it in a right we may just moronic ms
moronic we just take the telus menten
kinetics and just anything goes it is
moronic it is however interesting that
you get something in response to generic
boundary conditions which is so so sleek
lifelike so the tire gene is something
which gradually coming eventually
unsaturated yeah but at your age later
nothing yeah yeah and levels of chosen
such that at the end here you have it
here at all this involves via downhill
optimization okay so we have we have
evolved yes the emergence of this time
regime does it always happen no no some
things get stuck and they die it has
happened more than once not every time
but you know but is it is it the only
solution all the only one that we have
found that will do it those boundary
conditions not a proof we've looked at
proofs so we have evolved lots of other
systems which I show you here so which
are published so you just read the stuff
i will mention just to give you the
flavor exam a couple of minutes a couple
of other systems which are of interest
and for which these types of algorithms
work and which are rather informative
those means we could not have guessed
these dynamical systems i could not
guess these are amiable systems nor can
i optimize parameters for them by just
writing down something so this is useful
engineering right engineering simple
things for simple problems but you know
their predictions right or wrong so t
cell activation you know that t cells
will respond to a few molecules of
agonist they will do so in a sea of self
molecules and it's reasonable to assert
that the difference between self and
agonized is a factor of three to four
and operate bind to the receptor but can
you translate the english word mechanism
okay so tell us once a nap so agonist
agonist is the thing is the thing that
is going to trigger the response so
Agnes is a pee
some protein on the surface of an answer
in presenting cell which the T cell C so
it's the farm thing enemy self itself we
should what you don't want to react to
and the difference between the two is a
my experiments a factor of three or four
in it off rate so very modest I eat a
factor one-and-a-half Katie and binding
so to speak nonetheless you very
reliably activate and response to the
foreign thing in the in the presence of
a ten to the fourth excess and
concentration surprising kinetic
proofreading will not do this if you
look into the details so what works was
suggested by Alton Bonet and Jermaine in
this paper and what it involves is a and
this was that evolved by Francois and a
postdoc and we also played around with
it in this paper here the system is
ligand binds to receptor there's a
phosphorylation cascade in kinetic
proofreading with the important
difference that part way down the
Cascade you will create and activate a
phosphatase which then will then act on
the Cascade this system which does not
look obvious was evolved solves the
problem and happens me what these people
suggested it is not a trivial system but
does this which is also not trivial
problem number two is optimal decision
theory this is a branch of statistics
that came to the fore presumably due to
the exigencies of the Second World War
it will it will answer questions such as
these if I take a stream of data from
distribution air distribution be and I
wish to make a decision in as short a
time as possible as to whether i'm
seeing a or b where they give it with a
bound on the false positive rate what is
the algorithm and what is the fastest
decision time another problem would be a
change point problem IE i have a stream
of data from distribution a at some
unknown time the data will change to
distribution be i wish to predict that
time when i would be starts with a short
delay as possible and with a bound on
the false positive rate also a useful
thing to different
so these problems were all solved by
people in statistics world long ago this
one amusingly was first solved by sherry
I F in 62 who was a student of
kolmogorov so good pedigree and he was
working at some cyber Knights Institute
who's a thankless task was to monitor
the quality of Soviet factories ie when
do you shut that when does the junk
coming out look so bad you are shut down
production line and for that he did good
mathematics which has far outlived the
output of those Soviet factories in any
way this literature only met so
obviously century systems either
cognition ie when does that move it in
the grass say there's a tiger there or
just the wind blowing or sells an embryo
many case in biology you could imagine
want to do fast decisions nonetheless
this literature only entered the neural
world the paper shade and around then
and in the cellular world even later and
this last thing which I mentioned we can
show that simple biochemical networks
can get close to optimal and you could
up you could choose the parameters via a
simple search so this pawn can be easily
solved do you have so you have the
circular ready yes I'll player here we
pulled around you we did apply
mathematics I confess this was partially
by this is partially by design lastly
going back to the arthropods again a
work of Patel down down the hill
arthropod evolution can be schema ties
by this double funnel the what is common
to all arthropods is the segmented
pattern as displayed by the in Grail
jeans on here that is the silicone
so-called follow typic stage upstream of
that you have genes that are more and
more variable as you look across species
and there's sort of funnel so what Mike
Levine did so again down the hill was to
look at the gap gene so gap genes
regulate the parallel G so Yves apparel
gene gap regulates pair of all what's up
here if you compare fly and mosquito
the payroll jean-yves has its stripes
the gap genes which regulate it are the
same manifested the same genes tightly
homologous sequences are very close
etcetera however the position of these
gap jeans has moved right so giant has
moved and interchange with hunchback so
these position the captain said have
moved so we asked ourselves how is it
that you can preserve the payroll genes
and yet move around the gap jeans what
is the path which preserves function and
allows you to go from fly to mosquito
that is mathematically very analogous to
funding the saddle point so we have two
ground States we want to want to find
the most fit path going between them one
could run the evolutionary algorithm in
that way and that makes interesting
predictions about the ancestor
morphology between client mosquito which
is checkable okay this I will not
discuss okay fine so characteristic
these evolved models so firstly we are
evolving dynamical models nambucca
models that should be thought of as a
botanical system and you should think
about the topology of the flow the jeans
are things that you use to at the end
fit to the phenomenological parameters
and this has been done in some detail
and another problem where it is actually
very useful just as a technical thing
evolutions of course the cascaded
bifurcations it is important that both
the network and the parameters evolve
together if for example you took our
final Network scramble the parameters
and asked could you reappear for the
complex network the answer's no you'll
get stuck severe spices so it's very
important which was not a surprise that
you must evolve parameters and networked
together when you look at these
dynamical systems they are a mess truly
a mess right in so far as what you like
to do your sick people second generation
like to do as they did a 19th century
which is say something to slow
something's are fast can you eliminate
is something a function of something all
that goes out the window everything is
of order one it's an utter mess
nevertheless it is simple in that it can
all be found by local search gradient
search
everything I would have one when you
first start getting something resembling
the yeah the phenotype yeah yeah yeah
two dozen start off with no no it really
is always a horde of workers know and of
course if you look at development when
the fly is when the the the father is
gassed relating and doing its gyrations
with things moving here moving there
making the notochord during those
immense gyrations all the patterning is
happening as it as it builds spatially
geometrically the anterior-posterior
axis why the notochord it is at the same
time putting down the hawks pattern so
patterning and movement all happen
together is nothing sequential about
development it all has to go fast and
everything overlaps everything there's
no you don't wait we're asking whether
the selectors kind of driving things to
be yeah weather it weather weather when
a new gene of initially comes in you
have duplicated in fiber cakes for the
GE are you were ready to having jumps
aboard one yeah legally certainly when
we have all parameters we say choose a
parameter in this range yeah service or
episode we make johnson order one but
we're not making little jumps this is
sort of this is definitely
macro-evolution looking at file up etc
it's macro revolution so we're not going
to spend time right so obviously we may
be jumping over you know neutral or
slightly della terra we don't really
know you know as we say we make a new
thing choose primers of order one so
there is really macro evolution in that
sense but it's downhill okay in many of
these cases we could not guess the model
so there are qualitative things such as
for these harsh especially but many
others where we could not guess the
qualitative phenotype from the model but
it's trackable experiment so it's a
useful exploratory tool just like
analytics screen as a way of finding
things you couldn't guess the relevance
to experiment is that the love is at a
high level so to speak these properties
i mentioned for hawks IE how do you go
from short to long germ insects things
like that's the high level qualitative
phenotype that is predicted there are
much lower level phenotypes IE here's a
functional form with five parameters it
has the requisite dynamics there are two
thousand genes involved how do you fit
the
jeans to the five parameters that is a
useful data reduction and it's useful
because you have a minimal set of
parameters which gives you the correct
dynamical behavior for the embryo and
then you have to make your 5000 jeans
fit so last remark is when I those with
G only have to fit a small number four
emperors yes yes because it remembers
like it was right precisely right and
everyone speaks about the genotype to
phenotype map no one or very rarely says
what the phenotype is in quantitative
dynamical terms right which means a set
of different set of order differential
equations which have time parameters and
as a function of time give you give you
your shape right so it behooves one if
you want to use the term to actually
display the phenotype in some useful
form ie as a dynamical process so what I
have given you is simple 19th century
Darwinism I have asserted that if you
take it literally you will derive for
development interesting dynamical
systems which as an entering could be
right or wrong brettly's interesting and
it's very much a case by case study but
they're interesting cases and obviously
they motivate experiments thank
okay so why don't one of the one of the
okay how about that one okay so it all
of them may notice that there are lots
of self loops yes right and there are no
loops which are safe back to doing max
oh yes there certainly cycles so I just
like to bring two things firstly why is
that exactly is that okay um so the
revert be feedbacks are of course there
because I demand that when the mortgage
is gone I have stable state so I'm
manifestly am selecting for multi
stability i evaluate fitness at the at
time equals infinity when the market is
gone so I must have multi stability and
the fact that that they'll go back very
far is partially because some some grill
somewhere it's yeah yeah it that's it's
probably because I'm demanding multi
stability and the easy way to do that
it's just a feedback on yourself I mean
these things are composite genes
constraint no no no no no no no no I
just say you know here's a network pick
you know we definitely are saying here
the genes draw an hour anywhere on this
graph we're certainly are selecting
where we put the arrows at random that's
HD feature them the biology is not
ridiculous for the hox genes these
things are somewhat conflated be you
know it's the stuff sort of them are it
mean it's not ridiculous I mean the hox
genes they have very special regulation
this of course we're just dividing
phenotype it's not ridiculous that is we
got the hawks phenomenology so we have
the right regulatory properties for
hawks like we have posterior prevalence
and we have the time to space so we have
the right phenomenology
they are the regulation is immensely
complex they don't directly do that now
there's other ways but there's other
ways of becoming multi stable we may use
chromatin all sorts of things can I
think any question yeah I wonder yeah
yeah yes yes yes just wondering what
type of okay this gets very simple stuff
these things are all in the end of the
day you have a bunch of six points so
you could jiggle lots of stuff you stole
a bunch of fixed points so in that sense
you're very strong stability and I'll
see you jiggle enough you will move
boundaries but again we must be so the
sadistic intelligence of the network
that positions the selector genes is
that it rather robust it's evolved to
rather robustly read out the morphogen
or this top of this wave of morphogen
read it out in a robust way a noise
independent way
what is the as opposed to what may be
unstable ones we obviously don't are
thrown out or our family are disfavored
because again we about a fitness at pi
minus infinity I don't know offhand I
mean it's not absurd I mean yours we get
a movable acceptance right if you will
okay it is a pinch application so that
is another level of we've thought about
that in other words it is true in the
embryo as you probably know that
anterior that AP and DVR separate
systems now assume you you asked why is
that and if you think about stability of
dynamics of a local systems it's much
easier to make a stable pattern system
in one if you make it if you force to be
1d it's also very good for stability if
as you make the dynamics as in the
embryo you're basically pulling out the
AP axis but also suppresses instability
so making it one dimension is a is a
much more robust strategy to make a
pattern and try to let it flow on 2d at
once and control everything and the
embryos do even we don't we haven't
selected we have assumed this 1d but if
you ask me or why is it why he was 1d I
think there are magnets reason for that
to which couldn't come out we have not
done that but I would imagine if we
tried to you know try to make a pattern
you would want to do it as Cartesian I
think we should probably continue in the
hockey rink serving its coffee if you
can come back it 1030 on the sounds of
battle